you got people that have ideas that they
haven't quite figured out who they're
gonna sell it to it's just a good idea
you know and that doesn't work for me
like for me
everything that I've involved myself
with is there's a target audience and
well I hate yeah I'm so tired of niche
like niche is something that like I'm
glad to see go away and from this past
decade like it makes sense I guess like
it makes sense like after the after the
internet like that model makes sense for
a lot of things that guess like making a
niche but like I think we just needs to
be smarter like making making a product
for only a select few
you can definitely sustain that product
but I feel like the risk that you take
of like maybe it's good for everybody
it's worth it because you know I only
want to make things that are going to
reach as many people as possible I don't
believe in the niche like I think that
that is a really lame way that that that
comes from wanting more money yeah you
know like or just like being able to not
even more money but stable money because
you know you can get and I'm just like
I'm not interested in making things safe
thank you guys so much for watching
I made this series because I wanted to
promote understanding and awareness I
wanted you to see that it's not always
looking at it as one thing or the other
but if you embrace the genius of the end
and bring those two seemingly opposite
points of view together that that is
where the true genius lies I want you to
see that you can learn from both of the
people that are profiled in the video
especially probably from the person who
you don't immediately agree with if you
can understand their perspective and
apply it to your life chances are it'll
help you get to where you want to go
a lot faster so let me know what you
think leave a comment below I'll join
the discussion continue to believe and
I'll see you soon